If you can't sleep, can you take a little honey?
Yeah, so that would be some carbs, drinking some tea with some honey in it might be good.
Help you go back to sleep.
That's where I mean, in old days, your mother would give you a glass of milk and help you
warm milk, help you fall asleep. Why? Because there's sugar in it and it gives you sugar for
your brain to help you fall back asleep. That's why stress is an issue that why I can't sleep,
but you have stress. Because your cortisol is just bouncing all over or your cortisol levels have
spiked because of your stress all day. You're worried all day, your cortisol is just burned out
and you're in a adrenal fatigue at night and you don't have the cortisol to break down
the glycogen, and so.